obviously you've got a lot of big
projects going but you're a game show
host now yeah yeah I hosted a game show
hasn't come out yet but yeah it was a
crazy experience and I I really have I
feel like I have this appreciation now
for what you do like I had never walked
out to an audience cheering and say
hello and then talk to to contest it
like it's really a crazy it feels like a
like a like you're on the running man
the entire time which is obviously in
reference that really lands but I have
this appreciation for what you do which
I feel really comes down to the talent
of acting interested when people say
stuff
if you I'm doing if you want him to
respond you got to say his name oh okay
right I really I really feel like I have
this appreciation for you now
because what I think it really comes
down to is being like looking like
you're interested when people say stuff
Conan yeah I would say one of the things
that you will probably find as you do
this first of all did you tape a whole
season how many of these did you tape we
taped I think eight of them and what's
the premise of the you know called don't
and it's all about people not doing
things or trying to resist doing things
money from not doing some like don't
blink your eyes and stuff like that
right so it's see it's it's it's I mean
they're a I see so it's it's watching
someone try not to do your thing that
they would not actually want to do okay
and did you like it did you like doing
yeah he's like do you like being a game
show host
sure I yeah no I did I just don't feel
like it it feels like a weird dream that
happens but yeah it's real and I did do
it so we'll see